what do you think Elon hero or villain
that's pretty split halfway at the
moment the idea that like he could
figure out spaceships and not Twitter
Twitter isn't like a hard thing have you
ever met someone in Tech they're not the
best like socializing human beings
Zuckerberg has to like be reminded to
Blink right like his eyes dry out oh I
like MMA I like surfing blink okay there
you go right these aren't the people
that are good at socializing and they
figured out apps around socializing Elon
can figure out how to just write
something and post it it's not that
difficult I have no question he's gonna
figure out it's gonna be better they'll
have a billion users they'll find out a
way to monetize it it'll be easy